the Ukrainian flag is flying once again
in the southern city of Herson after
Russia said it had completed its
military withdrawal so what is the next
stage in this war let's bring in our
defense and security analyst Professor
Michael Clarke professor before we get
to the next stage I just want to get
your reaction to what we're seeing
happening in her son today yeah a very
dramatic day
um Russian forces have been moving out
for about a week not just in her son
itself but further up the river as well
at uh slavska that we've marked there
and around novakovka which is a really
important area really important Place
mark on the map so they've been
withdrawing and it looks as if they've
got a lot of their heavy equipment out
of the way but the collapse today what
looks like a collapse of the forces they
left in person is fairly dramatic and
very humiliating for the Russians the
ukrainians I think will be careful they
have said that they expect there to be
lots of mines and booby traps and maybe
Special Forces the spec snats left
behind in order to exact a prize for
this so I think they might be cautious
but it's a big okay undoubtedly a big
day this is the only significant City
the Russians took in February and now
they've lost it now they annexed it
didn't they it was uh six weeks ago they
annexed it and they said President Putin
said again it will be forever Russia
forever Russia Russia didn't last very
long indeed no but oh are we sure that
the Russians are actually withdrawing
yes uh 48 hours ago we wondered uh if if
they were playing a different tactical
game but yes they they are withdrawing
and it I mean there may still be some
fighting curse and I suspect there might
be some rough Justice on the streets
people who regard as collaborators maybe
some Spetsnaz forces then civilian
clothes Left Behind it's tough isn't it
Urban Warfare absolutely absolutely and
we know that the Russians sent some
um film Crews into person a few days ago
apparently to film whatever was going to
happen I think they'd like to pin the
blame for any fighting that goes on on
ukrainians as they were invading the the
Russians who really want to be in person
that's the the sort of narrative they'll
create so it's very difficult the
problem that the ukrainians are going to
have is that the Russians will be the
other side of the river and they'll
still be able to bombard person in the
way they bombarded Mario parlorsking
what they tried to do he can't give you
know they tried to take heart cave this
is the second City up in the Northeast
they failed so then they stood away from
it and bombarded it and the ukrainians
had to work very hard to push them far
enough away out of artillery range so
the ukrainians will have to try to push
them another 30 kilometers or so East
that won't be easy and I suspect that
they'll have to do that somehow from the
north so I think there's another quite
big battle developing which will
probably start I've always said this
I think the Ukraine is if they can if
they can might try to cross the river
and then put pressure on the Russians
from the north so the Russians have to
withdraw a bit further if they leave
them on the East Bank of the river then
almost for sure the Russians will just
bombard person with
and the hydroelectric power and the
canal the the Crimea Canal runs from
there which supplies water to Crimea but
the Russians the ukrainians have said
the Russians are preparing they've mined
the dam and they might blow it up
wouldn't it it would it well it would it
would flood the valley it would flood
more on the uh on the the Eastern side
than the West that's just how the land
lies it would take about between 19 and
20 hours for the water from the dam to
reach the Black Sea so it would be an
ecological catastrophe but of course it
would flood more the areas that the
Russians are now digging in on so it it
wouldn't make a lot of sense from that
point of view but you know who knows
what makes sense in the Kremlin these
days
um they're in a very peculiar mindset uh
as this process goes on just finally
let's take a step back every war ends in
negotiation doesn't it we've had a top
US general saying the retreat from
Castle means there's a window of
opportunity now for some sort of Peace
talk some sort of negotiation I mean how
realistic do you think that is is that
going to happen yeah don't hold your
breath and this is all about the G20
Summit next week in Bali and President
Putin said he won't go because the last
time you went to a summit was the
Shanghai cooperation organization
meeting in September and he was
humiliated amongst people who actually
quite like him and he came away from
that really angry and humiliation why
why what happened well because he's
lacking power he's losing the war and so
they took their chance to make him wait
for them to leave him on the stage by
himself to embarrass him even you know
the the presidents of of smaller
countries let alone the the Turkish
president and the uh the prime minister
of India and Xi Jinping of China of
course you know made it pretty clear
he's not doesn't really approve of the
way the war was going so he's certainly
not going to go to Bali and be even more
humiliated so he sent lavrov to be
humiliated now the point that what may
happen at Bali next week is talks about
talks but I'm certain they won't be
about a negotiated end to the war they
might turn into talks about talks
between the militaries for maybe a
ceasefire in place that's the best you
can hope for okay well we'll see you
next week barley
um Professor Michael Clarke thank you as
always so interesting